of today's round dario schwarz with us
here at the studio
and he gets to keep his scholarship
he didn't know what it was
it came very closely
you had your coach
going up and down a sideway roller
coaster of emotions it must have been
one of those rides for you as well
especially after coming off three losses
this game was
so close to winning
and then all of a sudden it turned into
a little bit of a fight take us through
this game that you managed to pull off
in the end
yeah i mean so the game was very
complicated since the very beginning i
didn't expect really neither for mostly
expected other openings but it was
impossible to play against jeffrey he
played so many openings so it was
you know tough to prepare but i looked
at bishop g5 a little bit for wesley
actually so
that's why i decided to play all the
hills against jeffrey
and uh yeah um jeffrey played this queen
b6 line uh poison pawn i decided to go
h6 win b6 so i have this possibility of
playing a3 and then i play this idea
bishop d3 let's pull that up on the
screen yeah knight d7 and actually here
after 97 uh sorry we should have two uh
bishop c4 is the most critical as far as
i know uh but i could not recall like
anything here so uh bishop c4 fashion is
critical but i've disciplined bishop f2
queen 7 bishop d3 which is an idea that
i looked at some time ago i didn't
really remember much but i think it's
some lines
black's supposed to play through e5 but
maybe because the seventh highlighter at
first on bishop b7 i think after we
should be seven bishop d3 uh
then e5 it is possible and these two
unclear game has everywhere in this line
um
like and here i think i got very
promising position after long castle and
yeah here was funny line actually if
jeffrey went to play e5 for instance uh
because at first i thought g6 idea was
coming uh i mean with the idea of e5
then i was thinking to play knight i
mean 95 is not possible but uh i have
right now knight d5 knight takes d5 it
takes d5
bishop yeah bishop takes d5
and now i have bishop takes b5 this was
like what i calculated i think it works
it takes b5 knight xb5
and uh if queen moves i have rook takes
d5 and i think i win a pawn and i have
very good position because in the end
there is four knight c7 you show that
line yes so
yeah and rook takes d5 uh 2597 this is
what i calculated and i win a queen of
course jeffrey wouldn't take on d5 but
still i think it's better for me uh
i can
just defend the rogue or go back or
whatever it's just better so uh jeffrey
playing sc5 and this was a good move g4
i decided i have to go but g5 caught me
really
off guard so like i sort of i was not
expecting this move i was i was
surprised by this move i was thinking
jeffrey would play something like rook
c8 for example and i was thinking to
play h4 h5 g5 knight g4 bishop g1 maybe
or f5 i was considering my options here
i wasn't sure what's going on in some
unclear position
uh perhaps perhaps i'm better but you
know it's um it's sharp
but jeffrey played g5 which i thought is
inaccurate because i have i saw this
bishop g3 idea and uh that right now if
jeffrey would play uh
move
knight wait sorry queen to b6 if queen
to b6 i saw that i have knight f5
and e takes the f5 at x5 and basically
position collapses i believe this is
what i was thinking during the game
wow so uh yeah so yeah
double question mark interesting i mean
this this was very surprising to me too
but um
i didn't think that's so bad during the
game i thought it's actually interesting
because i don't have any e5 and i don't
have any at least i definitely didn't
know what i didn't have because take
visually five queen b6 i didn't see any
follow up there maybe there is something
but i couldn't find and i spent some
time but i just couldn't i find let's
say neither f5 i calculate it takes a
five shot takes a five and 96 and sort
of position is
of
i don't know maybe comp is winning here
but i didn't see how to
break through
sort of so that's why i didn't do it
and i just have to play simple rook f1
with some pressure uh queen b6 knight
befriending was a good move to try to
trade his knight and he did move knight
b7 back yeah my this was actually
critical moment because at this first
position i want to play just a4 just my
instinct was a4 after b4 a5 this typical
id and dispose pollution to hit the
queen
and uh
it looks good yeah your instinct why did
you do it yes
yeah but but then i still then i saw a
tactic
because there is uh instead of a4 i
played bishop f2 so i i play the idea of
playing f2
i play bishop f2 value of queen c7 i
bishop takes b5 but it doesn't work i
realized because there's a tax b5 knight
xb5 bishop basics which is what i missed
initially
uh and uh
i'm pinned there and like when i take
this six queen takes this is also
important and i couldn't find here
anything
uh so
that's why you know i sort of realized
that i can do that and i did and i
played my initial plan with a4 stick
back to my main plan but
you know it's still i think it's still
good enough
yeah and i see three uh night fighters
looks reasonable and this king is right
now is very very weak now when you saw
this king you must have thought this
guy's got to die quickly yeah that's
what i was thinking i was
like trying to
i don't know i was expecting the game
will conclude before time control
but suddenly it wasn't so easy and
jeffrey was like defending really well
and i couldn't
like maybe for sure there was there were
ways but i just couldn't find them uh
yeah i think it would be free and rouge
e3 was reasonable as well and now this
was a very interesting moment because i
was thinking here knight takes e6 should
win
ah that's the one i said uh but i think
it doesn't maybe i mean at least this
one thing during the game rook takes f2
i calculated
quintex f2
uh knight x e4
and now uh the point is probably i could
play queen f7 and win but still some 92
tricks i wasn't entirely entirely sure
here so i was that's why i didn't do it
basically
here
be free uh
queen bee free i do take well i miss
counting material
yeah 98 98 i think i take on on the rook
not the right yeah it will be sure the
admissions will be hanging right
yup yup that basically so yeah i saw
such lines and i wasn't sure
uh
better probably but actually i'm way
better like it's all defended so i'll
calculate it now rook f2 and the key the
key idea here after knight takes e6
rook takes f2
uh queen f2 knight takes e4 queen e3 was
my main idea f takes e6 and rook b3 is
what was sort of my idea all the way but
unfortunately he has knight d2
and this is what i calculated as well uh
and i didn't like it i think for a
reason
ouch
so that's why my message was played at
the free and probably wasn't the most
objective
did you see right here you had
you had another move a5 right oh oh oh
oh
oh
that's so nice yeah
that's messed up yeah yeah it's nice i
didn't see that i admit i didn't see
that
okay told us you know that so yeah now
we got this position here i was why did
this is simple i wanted to some have
something to hold on to i can exchange
some material so it looks wonderful and
then jeffrey's playing all these moves
yeah yeah
yeah he just won't lay down and die
he keeps coming at you yeah it was very
frustrating yeah it was very frustrating
did you have any doubts as this was
transpiring that maybe you're not
winning anymore i
felt to me i should be winning still
okay all the way and here i saw when it
was move 40 by the way net xp i thought
i have knight a6 under basics
so you get
and yeah here it's actually important we
move back one move uh
not to play queen a7
because then just simply c3 was a very
good move a queen a7 would not be a good
move because i will play black will play
queen king c queen eid and king c7 back
rook a7 king d6
and i don't see i mean in rook d1 there
is knight d2
so my queen on a8 and rook on a7 are
sort of misplaced i believe
that's why um i believe that what i did
was correct rouge several gay seven
first king beatrice
and if king takes a8 sorry if king c7
then i have queen a7 and
i have regulating queen 97 which is a
huge difference because i've always
after king d6 for instance queen a free
check also i can play just queen a6 any
time i want to trade queens and i'm
winning
um at least that also i can play i will
calculate the king d6 rook d1
knight d2 rook takes d2
uh king spawned xd2 queen a6 and i
thought this is winning as well
yes great queen trace queen's king c2
and that's on and it looks very very
clear yeah so uh that's but you know
jeffrey played correctly quintet and
here i thought initially it was just
completely winning but then it wasn't it
was easy at all uh bishop c5 was was a
good move by uh jeffrey uh i think but
i mean i think i have to play queen
maybe from practical point of view i
think is a must because i bring my queen
to e6 and after i bring my queen to e6
he has no checks
pretty much uh but this was the most
unfortunately expected rooksy
rook c2 we thought
queen e6 is a mistake really yes and we
thought rook c2 right away
f1
c1
c1 queen f5 king a2
oh just like that
yeah we have uh and the c3 pawn drops
yeah that's even sometimes
we can take it with the pawn yeah as it
turned out it
was it was remarkable because
right here with the move bishop d4 i
thought i'm winning here
oh bishop d before f6 yeah
i saw
uh yeah i saw that queen d5 king b4 ah
and i don't have rook c4 because queen
is on f1 i thought i have made there i i
forgot about queen covering it's
foursquare
oh yeah this makes sense
too many threats now yeah the vision is
much better that makes sense yeah
wow and after bishop he probably thought
you were winning too because
probably we're both the same bishops
same thing
after we shall be free i think this is
winning now you're rolling
yeah the
the very final finish was really yeah
he was still played
queen g1 he could still have played
queen g1 king a2 ponte xb2
and quintex e5 i believe this queen and
game must be winning
uh still some technique was required
yeah
we'd still be doing
like
comedy
yeah
but i believe my pawn is too advanced
and i have
too many checks i will capture response
good more good moment and bonus
this could have had your yours your
coach not too happy
to have to sit here for that ending well
no i would like to have dinner at some
point
queen and gay come on no no no you don't
need dinner no no but b4 must have felt
so sweet yeah before was
very nice
absolutely beautiful
you look like you're feeling a lot
lighter right now a lot better to have
finally won a game definitely after
three losses
um
honestly i don't feel like i play too
bad like for instance
fabiano just also played me yesterday
she's just playing way better
uh even though i i think i had pretty
decent position just one made one bad
move and
against player like fabiano is enough
and against lanier also he played
perfect game i believe and also put some
pressure against me and i could not
defend well
and wesley also you know i i sort of
lost them sorry like myself i goes
for
this in this rook and game should have
lost probably but i i lost it the three
players you just described yeah tied for
first yes
you helped their cause
you also played the best the players who
are playing the best in the tournament
you're not the only one they'd be yeah
so but yeah overall i'm pretty happy
with my play even though my score of
course could have been i guess maybe i
expected it to be better
i didn't want to lose three games in a
row let's start for the tournament but
i'm really happy to win today and uh
yeah looking forward to the
rest of the games and yeah let's let's
keep fighting glad to see a smile on
your face after such a win
hopefully it is a turnaround let's hope
to see some more yep definitely
congratulations wonderful